[Musique]
c'est dans 48 heures que le président
giscard d'estaing inaugurera
officiellement à paris le centre georges
pompidou
dès le 1er février à 10h ce centre
artistique sera ouvert au public
c'est une oeuvre considérable qui
suscite la passion car son architecture
ne peut laisser indifférent
voici le premier d'une série de
reportages que vous pourrez suivre ce
week end grâce à adam se nier on le
découvre entre les pignons re blanchi
les maisons du vieux paris où la vie
s'écoule immuable comme la scène
surpris on le montre du doigt c'est dans
le quartier beaubourg le centre national
d'art et de culture georges pompidou
[Musique]
un portrait de georges pompidou réalisé
par vasarely en noir et blanc selon la
technique de jeu visuel cher à cet
artiste dominent le haut d'entrée de
cette construction de verre et d'acier
unique en son genre né de la volonté
novatrice du président qu'on pique on en
parle partout et de mille manières mais
en un mot de quoi s'agit-il
la plus grande tentative culturel que la
france ait faite depuis le début de
social tue des robert bordage président
du centre georges pompidou
cinq cent mille mètres cubes une maison
de la culture d'une telle envergure ne
l'avait jamais mais c'est bien davantage
qu'une maison de la culture
c'est en fait l'accès libre ou payants
sont les cas ces jours sur sept de 10
heures du matin 10 heures du soir à de
multiples activités
c'est une bibliothèque rassemblant des
centaines de milliers de livres
publication et documents audiovisuels
c'est la possibilité pour tous
d'acquérir des connaissances
linguistiques
c'est un centre d'information technique
et esthétique
concernant les objets les plus variés la
vie quotidienne privé ou professionnel
[Musique]
ouais
c'est un musée d'art moderne d'une
qualité exceptionnelle et d'une taille
inusitée
ce sont des expositions temporaires
venant du monde entier partant pour le
monde entier
c'est un institut de recherches
acoustiques et musicales comme il n'en
existe aucun autre c'est un lieu réservé
aux activités culturelles enfants qu'ils
se sont des films des concerts du
théâtre de la musique de la danse des
conférences des colloques portant sur
tous les sujets dont l'histoire de l'art
en général et l'art moderne en
particulier
impossible de résumer en une image à
l'ensemble des activités aussi diverses
peut-être toutefois en montrant ce forme
de synthèse abstraite le monumental
tableau synoptique grâce auquel sont
commandés et contrôler toutes les formes
de sécurité et de confort
ce centre culturel
immense vaisseau ancré à paris près de
l'église saint amé
[Musique]